Direction look again another one
this is what happens when simmering
tensions boil over on Saturday night a
Hindu March in Leicester led to clashes
with Muslims bottles were thrown at
police as they tried to stop the
violence after weeks of unrest leaders
from both sides came together to call
for calm
we the family of Leicester
stand in front of you not only as Hindus
and Muslims but as brothers and sisters
we together
call upon the Insiders of hatred to
leave our city alone
Lester has no place for foreign
extremist ideology that causes division
its claims of a series of attacks by
extremists that brought Muslim
protesters out onto the streets on
Sunday
they claim their Community is being
targeted by right-wing Hindu
nationalists and say they've been
reporting attacks since May
there's a an ideology that has been
played out in the streets of Leicester
that maybe looked at a national scale
International level so we have seen in
India at this moment in time of the
treatment of minorities including
Christians including dalits and
including Muslims which is now being
transferred to the streets of Leicester
Indies who joined the march on Saturday
dispute that claim this man was injured
they both wanted to remain anonymous but
insist it was supposed to be a peaceful
protest against Muslim attacks on their
Community we just wanted to make a stand
that this is not fair on us that you
guys have been coming to our streets
breaking and smashing things so we just
organized a march to show the support
for our community we can't have this any
longer is this very rooted in right wing
Hindu ideology no it's just about taking
a stand we need more guys here bro
with the question for police is how to
stop this violence escalating I think
the um the long-term solution here is
definitely about dialogue and a
recognition of that there are numerous
elements to this that need to be worked
through one thing that's cool
and is the huge amount of misinformation
being spread online and in messaging
groups that's fueling tensions and
causing people from outside the city to
get involved
the causes of what happened here in
Leicester are complex the need to
resolve it crucial to stop the violence
from spreading Becky Johnson Sky News
Leicester